YOU. OK? THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US FOR THE FIRST OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN 2024. THIS ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE THE FIRST MEETING.
EXCUSE ME OF THE COMMITTEE SINCE
2010. IN 2011, THE COMMITTEE WAS
MERGED WITH THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE TO FORM THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR GO F WAS SPLIT. WHICH
BRINGS US TO TODAY'S COMMITTEE.
THE SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC
IN PERSON AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
OLD STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. WE HAVE TWO BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. UH, WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM. UM SO WE'LL WE'LL
WAIT ON THAT. UM WE WILL GO
AHEAD. MM. OH WELL, WELL FORM
WILL FUNCTION AS A SUB COMMITTEE
OK TODAY UNTIL WE GET THE
QUORUM. UM NOW, LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR WELCOMES. OH, I
THOUGHT WE COULDN'T DO THAT TILL
. YEAH, WE HAVE SEVERAL THINGS
TO APPROVE, BUT WE NEED THE
QUORUM. WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
WITH OUR FIRST AUTHOR. SENATOR
CABALLERO. UH, YOU PRESENT S¼ B
1140. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S¼ B 11
41ST. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS, UM AND ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WE CAN
RESTATE THEM AT THE END IF WE
NEED TO. SO AS YOU ALL KNOW FROM
THE EARLY 19 FIFTIES AND UNTIL
THE STATE DISSOLVED THEM IN 2011
, CALIFORNIA REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES OR R Dð S¼ USED
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
TO PAY FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS IN BLIGHTED
DETERIORATING NEIGHBORHOODS
AFTER R Dð, A S¼ WERE DISSOLVED
IN 2011. LOCAL OFFICIALS SOUGHT
OTHER METHODS TO RAISE THE
CAPITAL NEEDED TO FUND PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS AND REALLY THE
DISSOLUTION OF THE R Dð. A S¼
WAS A WAY FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
THEIR MONEY OUT OF THE RDAS AND
NOT BE CONTRIBUTING TO ERASING
BLIGHT. UM AS A WAY TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET. UM AND, UH AND,
QUITE FRANKLY, IN RESPONSE TO
SOME R Dð, A S¼ USING THEIR
FUNDS IN QUESTIONABLE WAYS TO
ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS
THAT WERE NOT BLIGHTED AND TO DO
GIVEAWAYS TO BIG BIG COMPANIES.
AFTER THE RDAS WERE DISSOLVED IN
IN 2011, THE IN RES IN RESPONSE
TO THE ELIMINATION OF THE R Dð A
S¼. THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED S¼ B
628 IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE
OFFICIALS TO CREATE AN ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT OR THE EIF Dð S¼. THE
EIEIF Dð S¼ CAN FINANCE PUBLIC
CAPITAL FACILITIES OR OTHER
SPECIFIED PROJECTS TO PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO THE DISTRICT OR THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY THAT
RESULT IN A USEFUL LIFE OF 15
YEARS OR MORE. SO THEY HAVE TO
BE, UM, CAPITAL CAP, REALLY
CAPITAL FACILITIES. SIMILARLY S¼
B 852 USING THIS MODEL CREATED
CLIMATE RESILIENCY, UM, IN 2022
OR èC Dð S¼ IN ORDER TO RAISE
REVENUE PLANNED CLIMATE
MITIGATION OR ADAPTATION
PROJECTS WITH THE FUNDING
MECHANISM TO IMPLEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS,
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE, FINANCE
DISTRICTS AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
. DISTRICTS ARE VITAL TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOLS TO AND
FINANCE, PUBLIC FACILITIES OR
OTHER PROJECTS OF COMMUNI
COMMUNITY WIDE SIGNIFIC. UM YEAH
, AT AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL, IT'S BASICALLY A WAY TO
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH A LONG
TERM FINANCING MECHANISM.
UNFORTUNATELY CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE LIMITED STAFF AND
RESOURCES AND FORMING THESE
DISTRICTS HAS PROVEN TO BE A
DUPLICATE TO HAVE DUPLICATIVE
PROCESSES AND ARE CUMBERSOME TO
INITIATE, CAUSING THEM TO MISS
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OPPORTUNITIES. SB 1140 WILL
REFORM EIE Dð AND èC R Dð LAW
TO STREAMLINE AND CREATE
EFFICIENCIES IN THE FORMATION
PROCESS AND EXPAND THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS IN THESE TOOLS CAN
FINANCE THE BENNETTS WAS, THE
BENEFITS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF E IDS AND
CDS TO ADVANCE THEIR MISSION TO
SUPPORT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
SPUR CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY
IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE,
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME ALLOW
ROBUST COMMUNITY NOTICE AND
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE. AND
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS, UM, THAT
THE COMMITTEE REQUESTED, UM,
MAKE THAT ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
SO I, I APPRECIATE THE, UH, THE
INPUT AND, UM IT I THINK IT MAY
MADE THE BE THE BILL A BETTER
BILL. AND THERE WAS, UM, A
REFERENCE IN THE ANALYSIS TO, UH
TO èC AND A DIFFERENT MECHANISM
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO
SIMILAR THINGS, AND I DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE OF
LOOKING AT èC TO SEE WHETHER IT
MAKES SENSE TO ADD THEM AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW, SO I'M NOT OPPOSED
TO THAT AS WELL, IF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THINK THAT
THAT MIGHT BE INAPPROPRIATE
CHANGE IN THE FUTURE, UM I
THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD POINT. AND
WITH THAT, I, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. UM
I'M AND I, UH, FAILED TO MENTION
HOW YOU HAD, UM, SHARED THIS
COMMITTEE IN ONE VERSION OR
ANOTHER OF IT FOR IN THE PAST.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I APPRECIATE
IT. OK UM, WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
NOW, TO OUR LEAD WITNESS TO HAVE
A WE DO NOT. THEY COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY, OK? IT IS THE
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION OF FRESNO.
OK SO, UH, DON'T HEAR FROM THAT,
UH, LET'S MOVE ON TO, UH,
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B
1140. PLEASE LINE UP. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KAK SAHOTA. I'M THE PRESIDENT
AND èC E Ó OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE REPRESENT OVER
800 ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS, NEARLY
300 JURISDICTIONS, ALL WORKING
TOGETHER TO CREATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE PLEASED
TO HAVE A LETTER OF SUPPORT AND
CONCEPT ON THIS BILL ONLY
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT COMPLETED
OUR FORMAL PROCESS OF TAKING
SUPPORT. BUT I WILL SAY THESE
TOOLS E Dð S¼ ARE BECOMING MORE
AND MORE POPULAR FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPITAL PROJECTS. AS THE SENATOR
SAID, THERE ARE ALSO THE
FORMATION PROCESS IS BOTH
COMPLEX AND COSTLY. AND SO WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE THAT THE SENATORS
TAKEN THIS LEADERSHIP POSITION
IN ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES. WE
SUPPORT THE BILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING WITH THE STAFF AND THE
SENATOR ON SEEING FUTURE
VERSIONS OF THIS, SO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OK SEE? NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? NÓ SEE
NONE. UM THANK YOU TO ALL THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. DO ANY OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? YES
THANK YOU. UH I ACTUALLY DO
APPRECIATE THIS. I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW BEING ON LOCAL
COUNCILS. ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IS A PRIORITY. IT'S ALSO A BIG
STRUGGLE FOR SMALLER TOWNS. UM
THE CITY OF HAYWARD, FOR EXAMPLE
, HAD ONE INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
WORKING IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
UNTIL WE SEVERAL YEARS LATER, WE
TRIED TO HIRE SOMEBODY ELSE. UM
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S
LARGELY AREAS THAT HAVE SMALL
MOM AND POP SHOPS AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
TERRITORIES THAT ARE WHERE THEIR
BUSINESSES ARE THAT NEED THE
MOST HELP. UM SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU FOCUSING ON THIS
AND OBVIOUSLY, THE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS ARE THE BIGGEST
DEAL TO MAKE SURE THAT AN
ENVIRONMENT LOOKS NICE AND, UH,
FEEL SAFE AND SO FORTH. UM SO
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS AND
AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. AS SOON
AS WE GET OUR QUORUM, WE WILL
ACCEPT YOUR MOTION. THANK YOU.
SENATOR THANK YOU. UM SO A LOT
OF THESE FINANCING DISTRICTS, UH
, CITIES HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
OVER THE YEARS, YOU KNOW, I
SPEAK A LOT ABOUT THIS WITH THE
BONDS AND STUFF LIKE THAT IS
WE'VE KIND OF ERODED THE PUBLIC
TRUST. AND SO ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS FOR ME WHEN
WE'RE DOING ANY CHANGES, LIKE
THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT
EVEN GIVING THE APPEARANCE THAT
WE'RE REDUCING TRANSPARENCY OR
EFFORTS TO BE TRANSPARENT WHILE
WE ARE DEVELOPING THESE THINGS I
DO. IT SEEMS YOU'RE, UM UH SOME
OF THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. AND SO I'M GONNA, UH,
TAKE OUT ANOTHER LOOK AT THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND SEE IF THAT HELPS
ME RISE TO THE LEVEL OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT BEING LESS
TRANSPARENT AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
AND AT THE SAME TIME
ACCOMPLISHING SOMETHING FOR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THEM TO GET IN SOME OF THESE
IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE THINGS.
UM BECAUSE IF WE DON'T IF WE IF
WE KEEP DOING THINGS THAT ERODE
TRANSPARENCY, UH, WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT
TIME, UH, DOING FINANCING WHEN
IT IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE. SO
UH, SO ANYWAY, UH, I'LL PROBABLY
BE LAYING OFF OF THIS TODAY. UH
BUT I WILL. LIKE I SAID, LOOK AT
THE CHANGES IN THE IN THE UM UH
THAT THAT YOU MADE, AND, UH AND
SEE IF THAT WILL, UH, ALLEVIATE
ANY OF MY CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OK, UM. YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY MORE COMMENTS OR CLOSE?
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
YOUR I VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A
CORE. OK SO I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
THE AMENDMENTS. UH, REAL QUICK.
SO THE, UM MOTION WHEN WE
ACTUALLY GET TO HAVE IT, UH,
WILL BE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FROM COMMENTS TWO
THROUGH FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS. UH
ONE. THE INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EIF Dð FORMATION MEETINGS FROM
TWO TO THREE. UM AND I THINK,
SENATOR, UM, SAY THIS. THIS IS
MEANT TO BE TO ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERNS, AND SO THE SECOND ONE
IS TO REQUIRE THE PUBLIC
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO MAINTAIN
AN ILL MALE LIST OF INTERESTED
PARTIES AND UPDATE THAT LIST IF
MEETING TIMES OR LOCATIONS
CHANGE REQUIRE THE PFA TO
TRANSLATE THE NOTICES INTO OTHER
LANGUAGE. IS IF 20% OR MORE OF
THE COUNTY POPULATION THAT
SPEAKS ENGLISH, UM, LESS THAN
VERY WELL ALSO SPEAK THAT
LANGUAGE AND LAST TO RESTORE
NEWSPAPER NOTICES, BUT CLARIFY
THEY ARE SEPARATE FROM THE
MAILED NOTICES. SO WE HOPE THAT,
UM, WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR, UH,
ON THE ISSUES OF TRANSPARENCY,
SO HOPEFULLY UM, THAT, UH, PUTS
YOU IN A BETTER PLACE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. UM AND I WANNA JUST,
UH, THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THE BILL.
AGREEING TO THE AMENDMENTS AND
ADDRESSING AS SENATOR SEO SAID
THE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS UM I AM
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED WHEN
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC IS
AWARE WHEN THERE ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES AND
THAT THIS WOULD, UM THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD
BE, UH, COVERED, UM, DECIDING
WHETHER TO USE THESE TOOLS TO
FINANCE PROJECTS THAT TACKLE
ISSUES LIKE IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY IS SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMUNITIES UH, OF COURSE, UH,
REALLY DESERVE TO WEIGH IN ON,
UM WHILE THE AMENDMENTS ENSURE
THAT SOME COMMUNITIES RECEIVE
THIS INFORMATION IN THE
LANGUAGES THEY SPEAK AT HOME
MORE CONTINUES TO BE DONE. AND I
KNOW YOU'RE A BIG ADVOCATE FOR
THAT, UH, MANY COMMUNITIES RELY
ON ETHNIC MEDIA SOURCES. YOU
KNOW, THE SMALLER, UH,
NEWSPAPERS, UH, FOR INFORMATION
AND MORE INFORMATION I KNOW
NEEDS TO GO OUT IN INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE REST OF
THIS YEAR WITH THAT, UM, I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
UM, WILL BE TAKING A RECESS
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE THE OTHER
AUTHOR HERE ON HIS WAY, OK?
THE MEETING. WE HAVE OUR OTHER
AUTHOR HERE. UM SENATOR CORTESI.
DO YOU LIKE TO COME UP AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL? IS SENATE
BILL 12 209.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. UM AND
SENATORS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S¼ B 1209
, WHICH WOULD EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZE LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSIONS, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
LAFCO TO INDEMNIFY THE PURPOSE
OF LAFCO. COMMISSIONS INCLUDE
DISCOURAGING URBAN SPRAWL,
PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND PRIME
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN
ENCOURAGING THE ORDERLY
FORMATION AND DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL AGENCIES AND ENSURING THE
EFFICIENT DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT
SERVICES. UH, AF USE THESE
PRINCIPLES. VARIOUS LOCAL AGENCY
APPLICATIONS TO MODIFY
BOUNDARIES, ESTABLISH NEW
SERVICES AND EVALUATE AGENCIES
THROUGH THE PREPARATION OF
MUNICIPAL SERVICE REVIEWS AND
SPHERES OF INFLUENCE. FOR MOST
APPLICATIONS TO PUBLIC AGENCIES,
SUCH AS THOSE FOR LAND USE.
PUBLIC AGENCIES SUCH AS CITIES,
FOR EXAMPLE, PRIVATE PARTIES
INDEMNIFY THE INVOLVED CITY OR
COUNTY. LÀ COURSE ALSO WERE
INDEMNIFIED BY APPLICANTS UNTIL
THE SECOND DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEALS DETERMINED THAT LACO
COULD NOT REQUIRE
INDEMNIFICATION BECAUSE IT IS
NOT EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED IN THE
CORTEZ KNOX HERZBERG LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ACT WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO INDEMNIFY THE LAO
WILL NECESSARILY HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO MAKE
CONCESSIONS TO THE APPLICANT OR
TO NOT DEFEND ITS ACTIONS.
FUNDING FOR EACH COURSE IS
PROVIDED BY THEIR RESPECTIVE
COUNTY CITY AND SPECIAL DISTRICT
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO A
STATUTORILY DEFINED FORMULA THAT
SHARES THE COST PROPORTIONATELY.
SO ALLOWING TO USE
INDEMNIFICATION ESSENTIALLY WILL
PREVENT THE EXPENSE OF ONE
ENTITY FROM BEING SHIFTED TO ALL
REPRESENTATIVE AGENCIES. UH,
THAT FUND LAV THAT, IN TURN WILL
PROTECT COUNTIES, CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICT TAXPAYERS AND
RATEPAYERS FROM INCURRING THE
EXPENSES OF A APPLICANTS WHO
STAND TO BENEFIT FROM THE
APPROVAL AND APPLICATION. WITH
US TO TESTIFY TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HER CLIENT. UM WHO IS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS IS
JEAN HURST. YOU CAN. YOU CAN DO
IT THERE? YES. SORRY THAT'S OK.
I'M JEAN HURST AGAIN, UH,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSIONS. WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF S¼ B 1209. AS
SENATOR CORTESE MENTIONED THIS A
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
THAT AUTHORIZES LACO TO REQUIRE
AN INDEMNIFICATION PROVISION IN
APPLICATIONS AND CONDITIONS OF
APPROVAL. THE STATUTORY CHANGE
IS NECESSARY AS THE COURTS HAVE
RULED THAT LAFCO MAY NOT REQUIRE
NOR RELY UPON INDEMNIFICATION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT EXPRESSLY
AUTHORIZED IN THE COURT. CHAZ
ACT, EVEN THOUGH CITIES COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS ROUTINELY
REQUIRE INDEMNIFICATION WHEN
CONSIDERING LAND USE
APPLICATIONS AGAIN, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DELEGATED THE
POWER TO REGULATE THE BOUNDARIES
AND SERVICES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO AFS. UM M èC
MENTIONED LAFCO ARE TASKED WITH
DISCOURAGING URBAN SPRAWL,
PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND PRIME
AGRICULTURAL LANDS, ENCOURAGING
THE ORDERLY FORMATION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL AGENCIES
AND ENSURING THE EFFICIENT
DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT SERVICES
ON THE STATE'S BEHALF WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO INDEMNIFY ANY
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH LITIGATION
WOULD BE BORNE BY THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT FUND THE LAFCO.
ALTERNATIVELY THE LAFCO WILL
NECESSARILY HAVE TO CONSIDER
WHETHER TO MAKE CONCESSIONS TO
THE APPLICANT OR TO NOT DEFEND
ITS ACTIONS, WHICH UNDERMINES
THEIR FUNDAMENTAL STATUTORY
CHARGE. UH, WE WANT TO NOTE FOR
THE THAT WE HAVE HAD AN INITIAL
CONVERSATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ABOUT SOME CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE RAISED AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING THROUGH THOSE MATTERS
SUCCESSFULLY. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THE BILL
, AND THE HELPFUL ANALYSIS AND
SENATOR CORTESE FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THIS ISSUE
ON WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
MIX UP HERE. UM OK. ANY OTHERS?
UH, IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEN? YES. OK? UM MY NAME IS MEG
SNYDER. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE WITH AN IN
BETWEEN POSITION AS MENTIONED BY
THE SPONSOR. WE HAVE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDRESSING THEM IN
FUTURE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT? ANY ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. OK SEE NONE. I COME
BACK HERE. ANY QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES? OK THE BILL WHEN
IT'S WHEN WE HAVE THE CORE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OK, ANY
OTHER? QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
OK SENATOR CORTESI, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE OK, WONDERFUL. OK, UH WE
DO. YOU SAY? YEAH. YEAH WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET, SENATOR
CORTESI, SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD AND
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SHOW UP. I
UNDERSTAND. APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
BUT IT'S CALLED OH, HEY. YOU.
WHY YOU KNOW WHAT? MR. OK WE'LL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL WE GET THE
QUORUM HERE.
PRESENTED A OH MY GOD. ONE OF
THOSE POINTS. THANK YOU. OK WE
WILL BE, UH, COME BACK INTO
ORDER. OK? AND FIRST WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. IF OUR
ASSISTANT WOULD PLEASE SENATORS
DURAZO DURAZO PRESENT TARTO
HERE, SO YOU ARE TO PRESENT
DOLLY GLAZER. DINNER. SKINNER
PRESENT WAHAB W PRESENT. WIENER,
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE'RE GONNA
NEED A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
RULES. OH, WE HAVE TO SAY.
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES. OK, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A MOTION IS TO ADOPT COMMITTEE
RULE. SENATORS DURAZO I DURA, SO
I èC R TWO. AYE THEY ARE TO A
DOLLY GLAZER. SKINNER SKINNER. I
WAHAB WHAT HAVE I WINNER 4 TO 0?
THANK YOU. WE MOVE ON NOW TO
MOTIONS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WAHAB ON S¼ B 1140. THE
MOTION IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATORS DURAZO DURAZO, I SAY
ART TO SAY ART TO I DOLLY!
GLASER. SKINNER SKINNER I WAHAB
WAHAB IY WINNER 40 0. THANK YOU.
UM NEXT, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WAHAB ON SB 1209. UH,
CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS
DURAZO I DURAZO, I SAY ARTO SEAR
I DOLLY GLASER, GLAZER EYE
SKINNER, SKINNER IW WAHAB. I 5
TO 5 TO 0. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
EVERYONE, UM THAT'S IT. THANK
YOU. AND UM OK? ON ALL OF YOU
BECAUSE HE ONLY VOTED ON ONE OK?
SO WE'RE GOING BACK TO S¼ B ONE
AND 40. AND CHOLERA. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
SENATORS DOLLY GLASER GLASER, I
WIENER 5 TO 0. HE DID. HE DID
THE SECOND ONE. YEAH BUT THE
COMMITTEE RULES YOU NEED RULES.
THE COMMITTEE RULES. YEAH, WE
HAVE FOUR. IT'S OK. OK SO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SENATOR THIS WAY SO
HE WANTS TO VOTE. OK WELL, JUST
HOLD IT. HOLD IT. HOLD IT. OK,
WE'RE GONNA I DON'T. YEAH, I
DON'T NEED YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS FOR A FEW MINUTES,
PLEASE.
MEETING AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH, UM OPEN THE ROLE ON
COMMITTEE RULES. MOTION IS ADOPT
. COMMITTEE RULES SENATORS DOLLY
BLAZER, WIENER WIENER, I 5 TO 0.
THE RULES WERE UP. THE RULES ARE
ADOPTED. NEXT WE CAN OPEN THE
ROLE ON S¼ B 1140. SO ASSISTANT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY SENATORS DOLLY WEINER
WEINER. I'M 6 TO 0. OK, THAT
YEAH. BILL IS OUT. OK OPEN ROLL
ON S¼ B 1209. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS
DOLLY WEINER WEINER, I'M 60 0.
GREAT. THAT THAT BILL IS OUT.
UM, WE HAVE NÓ FURTHER. HAPPY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, MADAM. THANK YOU
. WE'LL MAKE THAT AN OFFICIAL
PART OF THE MEETING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UH AND I
WANNA THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY, PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US.
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE,
COOPER, OPERATION AND
PARTICIPATION. WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.